[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich denke, es wird mal wieder Zeit für eine Linzertorte
und zwar eine Linzertorte 2.0.
Denn die alte Linzertorte,
die ist schon ein paar Jährchen her.
Und ich hatte damals auch noch
eine gefälschte Linzertorte gemacht.
Die besteht aus so einem Rührteig.
Da muss ich aber dazu sagen: Nicht erschrecken!
In dem Video war ich damals noch schwanger,
hochschwanger.
Das war so kurz vor der Geburt.
Und ich habe vorhin kurz reingeguckt mit dem Josh
und dachte so: "Oh, wow!"
>> JOSH: Ein großer Bauch.
>> SALLY: Ein großer Bauch
und dicke Wangen.
Und ich dachte immer so,
in meinen Schwangerschaften
habe ich gar nicht so viel zugenommen.
Aber doch, es waren immer 23 Kilo,
23 bis 25 Kilo.
Und ich dachte immer, nee, ich hatte ja nur einen Bauch,
aber meine
– ich hatte schon ordentlich auch was im Gesicht.
War schon...
Ja.
Jedenfalls machen wir jetzt eine Linzertarte in der Tarteform.
Und ja, heute einfach mal ein etwas anderes Rezept.
Ich habe hier zum einen diese Basiszutaten,
also so das Grundgerüst,
und dann noch verfeinernde Zutaten,
wie Zimt und eben einfach Gewürze,
die ihr nehmen könnt, aber nicht nehmen müsst.
Aber ich mache es heute so.
Dafür nehme ich
350 Gramm Mehl,
250 Gramm Haselnüsse,
140 Gramm Butter,
250 Gramm Zucker,
einen Teelöffel Backpulver
und eine Prise Salz,
ein Ei
und Vanilleextrakt.
Und hier habe ich noch die ergänzenden Zutaten.
Ich habe hier etwas Milch, in meinem Fall Hafermilch,
Bittermandelaroma,
etwas Kakao,
Kaffeebohnen,
Nelken
und Zimt.
Die Haselnüsse werde ich jetzt erst mal zerkleinern.
Wundert euch nicht.
Ich habe vorhin schon mal Haselnüsse zerkleinert.
Deswegen ist er nicht gespült.
[Musik]
[Scratch-Geräusch]
Hui! Mit Strom klappt es besser.
[Musik]
Frisch gemahlen sind Haselnüsse einfach am besten.
Und der Rest ist jetzt eigentlich relativ einfach.
Jetzt kommen nämlich alle Zutaten in die Rührschüssel.
Ihr könnt den Teig aber auch ganz gerne
und auch ganz gut mit der Hand verkneten
oder mit einem Handrührgerät.
Ich habe hier jetzt viele Haselnüsse.
Es gibt auch Rezepte, da werden weniger benutzt.
Aber ich finde, Haselnüsse sind so aromatisch,
da muss auf jeden Fall viel mit rein.
Dann das Mehl dazu.
Ihr könnt aber auch Mandeln benutzen,
falls ihr keine Haselnüsse wollt oder vertragt.
Die Butter.
Ach ja, was ich hier jetzt noch machen werde.
Ich habe hier auch Kaffeebohnen
– das mache ich jetzt auch zum ersten Mal,
hat nämlich eine gute Freundin von mir mir empfohlen,
die Sandra,
ist ein Omarezept –
und Nelken.
Und die kann ich jetzt hier im Mörser zerkleinern
oder im Mixer.
Aber ich würde es jetzt hier einfach im Mörser machen,
weil die Kaffeebohnen dann eben nicht so warm werden
durch die Reibung.
[Musik]
So.
Hach! Das riecht schon richtig gut.
Kaffee und Nelken, perfekt!
Dann noch Zimt mit rein
und Kakao
und alle anderen Zutaten.
Zucker, Salz, Backpulver.
Ein Ei.
Man kann das Rezept übrigens
auch supereinfach veganisieren.
Vegane Butter nehmen,
vegane Milch nehmen,
also Hafermilch zum Beispiel oder eine andere,
das Ei weglassen und einfach ein bisschen mehr Flüssigkeit
oder zum Beispiel geschrotete Leinsamen.
Dann noch als Tipp Bittermandelaroma
beziehungsweise -öl.
Etwas Vanilleextrakt.
Und jetzt noch der krasse Omatipp!
Und zwar jeweils einen Esslöffel
Rum,
Amaretto
und
Kirschwasser.
Die drei zusammen
oder ein bisschen Milch.
Ich nehme jetzt erst mal hier Hafermilch.
Jetzt alles schön verrühren beziehungsweise verkneten.
Und da muss ich auch echt sagen:
Diese Minimenge Alkohol, die verbackt da wirklich im Teig.
Also, wenn ihr dann wegen Kindern oder so Bedenken habt,
müsst ihr da echt keine Sorge haben,
weil es wirklich nur drei Esslöffel sind.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist der Teig fertig.
Und ihr könnt die Linzertorte
entweder in einem Backring backen,
in einer Springform, in einer Tarteform
oder, wenn ihr wollt, auch in so kleinen Miniburgerringen.
Denn dann könnt ihr kleine Linzertörtchen machen
oder Minitartes,
also so, wie ihr wollt.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach eine Tarteform.
Ich nehme jetzt mal die große 30er.
Denn so eine Linzertorte eignet sich auch hervorragend
zum Verschenken oder zum Vorbereiten,
weil sie eben auch lange haltbar ist.
Ich mache das jetzt so:
Ich sprühe die einmal kurz ein.
Und die haben hier so einen Hebeboden,
sodass die Tarte später eben auch wieder einfach rausgeht.
Kurz mit Backtrennspray einsprühen.
Dann nehme ich jetzt den Teig.
Und so ungefähr eine Handvoll
muss ich aber weglegen
für das Gitter obendrauf.
Und ihr seht, jetzt ist der Teig auch schön fest
wie so ein Mürbeteig,
zum Ausrollen eben.
Ihr könnt auch die doppelte Menge machen
und dann direkt so auf das Blech.
Das ist auch lecker.
[Musik]
Jetzt einfach so ein bisschen ausrollen.
Es muss jetzt auch nicht ganz gleichmäßig sein.
So ein bisschen Mehl drunter.
Das passt dann schon.
Und jetzt wickle ich das hier kurz auf.
Ihr könnt es auch direkt ohne Ausrollen
in die Form reindrücken.
Aber so habt ihr es gleich ein bisschen leichter,
es wird ein bisschen gleichmäßiger.
Und jetzt einfach mit den Fingern
noch ein bisschen ausbreiten
und schön verteilen.
Hier auch am Rand hochziehen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt, damit sie schön gleichmäßig wird,
schneide ich hier noch ein bisschen was weg.
Denn die Linzertorte soll gar nicht so hoch werden.
Das ist eher auch so ein flacherer Kuchen,
also nicht ganz tarteformhoch.
[Musik]
Ich sehe schon wieder die Kommentare
unter dem Video, Josh.
Denn die Linzertorte kommt ja ursprünglich aus Linz,
aber da wird die halt so ganz anders gemacht als bei uns hier.
Denn in Linz
wird sie mit Ribiselmarmelade gemacht
und ist halt eher hell, also ohne Kakao.
>> JOSH: Echt?
>> SALLY: Ja. Und bei uns ist sie halt so total mit Gewürzen,
Nelken und so weiter.
Aber ich muss sagen, dass uns die Version
– also dass mir persönlich und auch uns hier
die Version besser schmeckt mit Pflaume.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich finde die schon gut.
So.
Das ist jetzt erst mal die Form.
Und jetzt habe ich hier Pflaumenmus,
aber auch Aprikosenmarmelade.
Die vermische ich jetzt.
Das war nämlich auch so ein Omatipp.
Und hier könnt ihr auch gerne Kirschwasser noch dazu geben.
Das macht ja eigentlich schon so den typischen Geschmack
der Linzertorte aus,
zumindest die, die man in Baden kennt.
Okay.
Und jetzt kommt hier
die Marmelade rein.
Bist du eher so Team Viel Marmelade
oder eher so Team Wenig Marmelade?
>> JOSH: Ah, ich würde schon sagen, viel Marmelade,
weil ich mag es bei Linzertorte nicht, wenn sie zu trocken ist.
>> SALLY: Ja, die darf nicht trocken sein.
Die muss so richtig
saftig, matschig sein eigentlich,
>> JOSH: Ja, genau.
>> SALLY: nicht so weit gebacken.
>> JOSH: Genau.
Dann am besten so ein paar Tage ziehen lassen.
>> SALLY: Eigentlich müssen wir sie echt noch ziehen lassen,
bevor wir sie probieren.
Oh, das sieht so lecker aus jetzt schon!
[Musik]
Und jetzt gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten der Dekoration.
Sarah, die Food-Fotografin, hat sich mehrere gewünscht.
Also wird es heute nicht nur eine Linzertorte geben,
sondern gleich mehrere.
Die erste Version ist:
Wir rollen jetzt den übrigen Teig aus
und schneiden Streifen zu.
Das zeige ich euch jetzt mal.
Und, damit die Streifen schön gleichmäßig werden,
setze ich hier jetzt meine Abstandsrollen drauf.
Ich denke, ich nehme 3 mm.
Aber die muss ich kurz holen.
[Musik]
Dann am besten einmal mit der Palette drunter lösen.
Jetzt habe ich hier so ein Zickzackrad,
also wie so ein Pizzarad.
Und das ist auch stumpf.
Deswegen kann ich auch hier auf der Matte schneiden.
Ansonsten bitte von der Matte runternehmen.
Und einfach so kleine Streifen zuschneiden.
Einmal den Rand weg.
Das ist eigentlich so die ursprüngliche Art,
wie man das auch immer gemacht hat.
Aber ich muss sagen, mittlerweile
mache ich es auch ganz gerne mit dem Spritzbeutel.
Das zeige ich euch auch gleich.
Aber das ist halt schon auch schön.
[Musik]
Und jetzt legt ihr hier
die Streifen im Gittermuster drüber.
Aber ich muss sagen, das ist halt schon
so ein bisschen aufwendiger.
Wie sieht die Linzertorte bei deiner Oma aus?
Ist die auch mit so einem Gitter, oder?
>> JOSH: Ja, ganz traditionell mit Gitter.
>> SALLY: Ui!
Da siehst du mal, mit wie viel Liebe die Oma das zubereitet.
Wie heißt sie, die Oma?
>> JOSH: Gerda.
>> SALLY: Oma Gerda.
>> JOSH: Die guckt sogar deine Videos.
>> SALLY: Hallo, Oma Gerda!
Ich hoffe, dass meine Linzertorte
mindestens genauso gut schmeckt wie deine.
Aber der Josh, der wird nicht sagen,
die schmeckt besser als bei der Oma.
Der wird sagen: "Die schmeckt bei der Oma Gerda besser."
Aber ist okay für mich.
[Musik]
Hier nehme ich jetzt kurz die kleinere Form.
Ich habe nämlich noch einen Teig gemacht.
Und wenn ihr das jetzt mit dem Spritzbeutel macht,
dann sollte der Teig ein bisschen weicher sein.
Das heißt, da gebe ich jetzt einfach noch Milch dazu.
Und die Haselnüsse,
die sollten auch ein bisschen feiner gemahlen sein.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt hier einfach noch mal
eine feinere Portion gemacht.
Zum Weicher-werden-Lassen
gebe ich Milch dazu
und verrühre das kurz.
Und das ist eigentlich schon so
die zeitsparendere Methode, muss man sagen.
[Musik]
Und dann kommt dieser Teig in einen Spritzbeutel.
Wenn ihr habt, geht auch eine Gebäckpresse.
Da müsst ihr den Teig auch nicht so ganz flüssig machen.
Also flüssig ist er ja nicht, aber schon ein bisschen
streichfähiger als jetzt der feste Mürbeteig.
Und dann
könnt ihr das Gitter einfach damit aufspritzen.
[Musik]
Und, weil es hübsch aussieht,
auch eine Umrandung.
Oder? So eine Umrandung ist schon so ein Muss.
Wenn man es ganz perfekt haben will,
macht man hier noch den Rand weg.
Aber das wäre natürlich nur was für Perfektionisten.
Seht ihr einen?
>> JOSH: Mh.
Da.
>> SALLY: Und wo?
>> JOSH: Da.
Da. Da ist einer.
>> SALLY: Ach so, ich kann die eigentlich schon backen
bei 170°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
[Musik]
Okay, vielleicht will ich die auch noch kurz perfekt machen
vor dem geöffneten, warmen Ofen.
[Musik]
So.
Das verläuft dann aber ein bisschen im Backofen.
Also das muss ich euch auch sagen.
Die kommt jetzt auch in den Backofen.
Und die dritte Möglichkeit wäre
für eine schöne Dekoration,
dass ihr den Mürbeteig, wenn er noch so schön fest ist,
als Sternchen ausstecht und die Sternchen obendrauf legt.
Vielleicht mache ich das auch noch.
[Musik]
[Scratch-Geräusch]
>> DENNIS: Seid ihr am Drehen?
>> SALLY: Ja, wir sind am Drehen.
>> DENNIS: Oh, sorry.
>> SALLY: Ich backe eine Linzertorte!
>> DENNIS: Was backst du?
>> SALLY: Linzertorte.
>> DENNIS: Was ist eine Linzertorte?
[Scratch-Geräusch]
>> JOSH: Nicht dein Ernst, oder?
>> SALLY: Veräppelst du mich jetzt, oder?
>> DENNIS: Nee.
>> SALLY: Kennst du keine Linzertorte?
Linzertorte? Nee, kenne ich nicht.
>> SALLY: Mit den Mustern drauf.
>> DENNIS: Nee.
Ich glaube, das hast du mir schon mal gesagt.
>> SALLY: Ah!
Okay. Warte, warte!
Hier in der dritten Portion habe ich noch keine Butter drin
und noch kein Ei.
Ich mache dir die vegan.
>> DENNIS: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und dann probierst du später die Linzertorte.
Und du hast noch nie was davon gehört?
>> DENNIS: Nein.
>> SALLY: O mein Gott! Ich backe dir eine Linzertorte.
>> DENNIS: Habe ich mich blamiert oder was?
>> SALLY: Ich mache sie vegan. Also...
Sehr gut, denn ich hatte die Butter schon abgewogen,
aber noch nicht rein.
Also ich mache jetzt vegane Butter rein,
lasse das Ei weg
und ich mache einen Esslöffel Leinsamen.
Die kommen jetzt einfach mit in den Mörser.
Und dann den Teig so zubereiten
wie den anderen auch.
Und dann darf Dennis später die vegane probieren.
Und Volkan, okay?
>> DENNIS: Sehr gut!
>> SALLY: Und Benny vielleicht noch.
>> SALLY: So alle Veganer.
>> DENNIS: Party gecrasht!
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> DENNIS: Das wollte ich ja schon immer mal machen,
dein Video crashen.
Tschau!
>> SALLY: Was wollte er jetzt eigentlich von mir?
Manchmal kommt er einfach so runter, gell?
>> JOSH: Ja.
Ich glaube, der hat gedacht,
er stört uns einfach mal so ein bisschen.
>> SALLY: Ich hole Leinsamen.
Dennis' vegane Linzertorte mache ich jetzt
mit Sternchen.
[Musik]
Passt das so für den Dennis?
Schon, oder?
>> JOSH: Ja.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hier sind jetzt die Linzertorten.
Jetzt wird verkostet.
Was ich noch sagen wollte:
Wenn ihr einen kleinen Rest noch habt,
dann könnt ihr zum Beispiel noch so kleine Sternchen backen.
Ja, für die Deko.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber man hat ja immer so am Ende
– weil man legt ja immer so eine Handvoll Teig weg
und dann macht man die Deko obendrauf
und dann hat man immer noch so eine Minihandvoll.
Und daraus macht man einfach Kekse.
Okay. Ich habe jetzt hier die klassische Version,
die vegane Version,
die Joshs-Oma-
Gerda-
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SARAH: Gretel.
>> SALLY: und-Sally-Version.
Also kommt! Wir probieren jetzt einfach.
Josh, du kommst auf jeden Fall.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Dennis, Volkan.
Benny ist leider schon weg.
Sarah.
Was ich aber dazu sagen muss:
Linzertorte
– das ist die Linzertorte übrigens.
>> DENNIS: Hm.
>> SALLY: Einmal klassisch
>> SARAH: Hey!
>> SALLY: mit Gitter.
>> JOSH: Für die Unwissenden: Linzertorte.
>> SALLY: Sen biliyor musun?
Kennst du Linzertorte?
>> VOLKAN: Ja, war haben das
>> SALLY: Gell? Wir haben das schon mal...
>> VOLKAN: gemacht.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> VOLKAN: Das habe ich zusammen mit Murat...
>> SALLY: Ja!
Echt?
>> SARAH: Ja! Echt?
>> SALLY: Habt ihr so was zusammen gebacken?
>> VOLKAN: Ja, ja, Linzertorte.
>> SALLY: Echt? Habt ihr das hochgeladen?
>> VOLKAN: Wir haben eine Torte gemacht. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ah, okay.
Also so mit einem klassischen Gitter.
War das eine Linzer? Das kann sein.
>> SARAH: Volkan, du bist nicht im Bild.
>> SALLY: Egal. Linzertorte...
>> VOLKAN: Aber ich kenne Linzertorte.
>> SARAH: Volkan, du bist nicht im Bild.
>> SALLY: Komm weiter rein. Ja, ja, ja.
>> SARAH: Sag bitte einmal für uns: "Doch."
>> VOLKAN: Doch.
>> SALLY: Nein.
Doch.
>> SARAH & VOLKAN: Doch.
>> MURAT: Nein!
>> SALLY & SARAH: Egal.
>> VOLKAN & SARAH: Doch.
>> SALLY: Also einmal mit Gitter,
einmal gespritzt
und einmal mit Sternchen.
Die dürfen wir noch nicht anschneiden.
>> SALLY & SARAH: Die ist für das Foto.
>> VOLKAN: Okay.
>> SALLY: Klassisch,
vegan.
Auch vegan.
Ah! Und übrigens hier Tartformen mit Hebeboden.
>> DENNIS: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Einfach ein bisschen lösen.
>> DENNIS: Riecht schon toll.
>> SALLY: Die hebt. So. Jetzt.
Und was ich vielleicht noch sagen muss:
Linzertorte isst man eigentlich nicht am gleichen Tag.
Man lässt es ruhen.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Weil jetzt ist sie noch ein bisschen hart.
Aber morgen, übermorgen und in einer Woche
ist sie richtig schön weich durchgezogen.
Macht das die Oma Gerda auch so?
>> JOSH: Ja, natürlich.
>> SARAH: Guck mal, wie eng wir aufeinander stehen,
in dem Bild.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: Also lang vor dem Geburtstag
wird da angefangen zu backen.
>> SALLY: Gell?
>> JOSH: Weil so eine Linzertorte ganz frisch ist eigentlich...
>> SALLY: Eigentlich ein No-Go.
>> JOSH: Man kann sie probieren so,
aber halt...
>> SARAH: Dann probieren wir sie halt morgen.
>> SALLY: Ja, wir probieren sie heute
und morgen
>> SARAH: Und übermorgen.
>> SALLY: und übermorgen.
Weil ich habe ja jetzt genug gebacken.
Oh, hoppala!
>> SARAH: Wir haben viel Linzertorte.
>> JOSH: Wie sollen wir jetzt
– ah ja, wir haben Gabeln.
>> SARAH: Ich habe Gabeln geholt für alle.
>> SALLY: Also vegano,
classico.
Ich finde, auch die vegane Version
also war megaeinfach zu machen.
>> SARAH: Du nimmst die goldene?
>> SALLY: Ich nehme die goldene.
>> SARAH: Die brauche ich für das Foto.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> SARAH: Das ist vegan?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Dann...
>> DENNIS: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Den kannst du ja auch probieren.
>> JOSH: Dann weg damit.
Ist das vegan?
Weg! Nee, nee, nee.
Mmh!
>> DENNIS: Amazing!
>> SARAH: Amazing!
>> VOLKAN: Amazing!
>> DENNIS: It's amazing.
>> SARAH: Unbelievable!
>> DENNIS: Mmh!
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> VOLKAN: Mmh! Richtig lecker!
>> JOSH: Also ich finde das Verhältnis
von Marmelade zu Boden
sehr gelungen.
>> SARAH: Hm. Hm.
>> JOSH: Mh.
Bei meiner Oma schmeckt es aber trotzdem besser.
>> DENNIS: Oh!
>> SALLY: Na klar!
Natürlich!
>> SARAH: Das hat er nicht gesagt.
>> VOLKAN: Der ist auch saftiger.
>> SALLY: Doch!
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> SARAH: Woah!
>> SALLY: Aber es ist so.
Seine Oma, die macht das halt schon
seit Jahrzehnten wahrscheinlich.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> DENNIS: Schmeckt super!
>> SALLY: Da komme ich
>> JOSH: Also ich meine...
>> SALLY: nicht dagegen an.
>> DENNIS: Schmeckt einfach super!
Das ist immer das Gleiche.
>> JOSH: Also du machst die zweitbeste Linzertorte.
Aber...
>> SARAH: Welche Marmelade ist das?
>> SALLY: Pflaume mit Aprikose.
>> SARAH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Liebe Oma Gerda, vielleicht
habe ich ja das Glück und darf mal ein Stück
von deiner Linzertorte probieren
>> JOSH: Bestimmt.
>> SALLY: und kann noch was von dir lernen.
>> SALLY: Oder?
>> JOSH: Ja, mit Sicherheit.
>> SARAH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und wenn die Oma Gerda
was grundlegend anderes macht,
dann bin ich dafür, dass wir das Rezept von der Oma Gerda
hier auch hochladen.
>> JOSH: Oh ja, da frage ich sie mal.
>> SALLY: Ja, mit der Oma Gerda zusammen.
Deal?
>> JOSH: Ja,
>> SALLY: Deal?
>> JOSH: wenn sie mag.
>> SALLY: Gell? Da kannst du sie mal fragen.
>> SARAH: Ich muss sagen, ich liebe es,
dass die noch warm ist.
>> DENNIS: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich liebe auch warme Linzertorte.
>> JOSH: Das ist halt der Vorteil, wenn sie frisch ist.
>> SALLY: Oh, ich finde aber...
>> SARAH: Ich finde, das Warme ist so weihnachtlich.
>> VOLKAN: Mandeln, nicht?
>> SALLY: Haselnüsse.
>> VOLKAN: Haselnüsse?
>> SALLY: Aber ich finde, dass wir ein richtig gutes
– also ein Statement abgeben können,
müssen wir morgen noch mal probieren.
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> DENNIS: Definitiv.
>> SALLY: Noch mal und übermorgen noch mal.
>> SARAH: Ja, können wir bitte das Gleiche morgen anziehen?
>> DENNIS: Die Woche durch
müssen wir es auf jeden Fall machen.
>> SARAH: Kannst du das Gleiche morgen noch mal anziehen?
>> DENNIS: Kann ich machen. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> DENNIS: Ja, das sollten wir auf jeden Fall machen.
>> SALLY: Also Linzertorte?
>> DENNIS: Ich würde auch gerne
einen mit nach Hause nehmen
>> VOLKAN: Richtig lecker!
>> DENNIS: und da auch noch mal testen.
>> SALLY: Linzertorte?
>> DENNIS: Daumen hoch.
>> VOLKAN: Gut.
>> SALLY: Platz zwei.
>> JOSH: Sehr gut.
Platz zwei, aber sehr gut auf jeden Fall.
>> SARAH: Woah!
>> SALLY: Also viel Spaß beim Nachbacken!
Und ich freue mich jetzt auf eure Linzertortenrezeptfotos.
Bis zum nächsten Mal! Tschüss!
>> VOLKAN: Tschau!
>> SARAH: Tschüss!
>> JOSH: Tschau!
>> DENNIS: Mmh!
>> VOLKAN: Da sind keine Mandeln drin?
>> DENNIS: Wahnsinn!
Mmh!
>> JOSH: Volkan, schmeckt dir das eigentlich so
>> SALLY: Bittermandel.
>> VOLKAN: Bittermandel, deswegen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> VOLKAN: Das war es.
>> JOSH: mit türkischem Geschmack?
Ja?
>> VOLKAN: Ja, ja.
>> SALLY: Schmeckt dir das?
>> VOLKAN: Es gibt so im Türkischen Törtchen mit Amaretto,
mit Bittermandeln.
>> SALLY: Ah, cool.
>> VOLKAN: Deswegen erinnert mich das.
Das hatten wir nicht gemacht.
>> SALLY: Weil...
>> VOLKAN: Wir haben was anderes gemacht.
>> JOSH: Weil ich hatte vorhin noch gefragt,
ob es in der Türkei eigentlich so was gibt.
Und...
>> VOLKAN: Ja, wir sagen dazu...
Nicht Pie.
>> SALLY: Weil in der Türkei
essen die nicht gern Lebkuchen.
>> VOLKAN: Ja, aber die haben irgendwas wie so.
>> SALLY: Ja, ja. Weil bei Lebkuchen, da sagen die immer:
"İlaç gibi" – "Das schmeckt wie Medizin."
>> VOLKAN: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und bei dem wusste ich jetzt nicht, ob die das...
>> VOLKAN: Wegen den Bittermandeln.
>> SALLY: Genau.
>> VOLKAN: Hm. Aber ich liebe das, Bittermandel.
>> DENNIS: Das schmeckt super!
>> SALLY: Okay. Also Test bestanden.
>> SARAH: Ich habe mich übrigens verliebt in Kaymak.
>> VOLKAN: Kaymak, ja.
>> JOSH & SARAH: Woah!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Josh und ich sind...
>> SALLY: Bal kaymak.
>> VOLKAN: Hm.
Kaymak, das beste Kaymak ist in Afyon.
Richtig lecker!
>> JOSH: Oh, da müssen wir jetzt leider noch hin.
>> VOLKAN: Leider nicht vegan.
>> SALLY: Next trip: Afyon.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> VOLKAN: Next trip: Afyon.
>> SARAH: Kaymak...
>> JOSH: Ripplinger und Palik
auf der Suche nach dem Kaymak.
>> VOLKAN: Es gibt auch richtig gute Sucuk in Afyon.
>> SARAH: Auf der Suche nach Kaymak mit Wabenhonig.
>> MURAT: Seid ihr immer noch am Abspann?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Mein Gott! Macht das Video fertig!
>> SARAH: Okay.
>> DENNIS: Es schmeckt halt lecker.
>> JOSH: Gut. Cut!
>> SALLY: Sollen wir abtauchen?
>> MURAT: Ja, abtauchen.
>> SARAH: Abtauchen.
>> SALLY: Eins,
>> SALLY & SARAH & VOLKAN: zwei,
drei!
>> VOLKAN: Ihr habt das falsch gemacht.
>> MURAT: So.
Wir sind zwei Jahre alt.
>> SARAH: He! Warum willst du meine Gabel?
>> DENNIS: Die Crew möchte gerne aus dem Kindergarten
abgeholt werden.
>> VOLKAN: So.
Drei Tage später.
>> SALLY: Also heute ist Tag zwei
– nee, Tag drei, nicht?
>> SARAH: Tag drei.
>> SALLY: Wir haben sie vor drei Tagen gebacken.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und gestern haben wir sie schon probiert
und es war schon richtig gut,
aber heute ist sie so Bombe.
>> JOSH: Jetzt, also jetzt hat sie so den Punkt erreicht.
>> SARAH: Jetzt ist es so Linzertorte de luxe.
>> JOSH: Schön durchgezogen.
>> SARAH & SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: Mmh!
>> SARAH: Richtig gutes Frühstück.
Ich will nur mal sagen, es ist zwanzig vor zehn.
>> JOSH: Pst.
>> SALLY: Morgens halb zehn in Deutschland.
>> SARAH: Linzertorte.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich wollte nur anmerken,
dass an meinem Teller eine Nudel klebte.
>> JOSH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> SARAH: Woher kommt die?
>> SALLY: Weiß ich auch nicht.
>> JOSH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Aus der Spülmaschine.
>> SARAH: Mmh!
Essensreste liebe ich!
>> SALLY: Du hast einfach das Stück Kuchen drauf gelegt.
>> SARAH: Ich wollte, dass du
die Liebe zu Essensresten mit mir teilst.
>> SALLY: Und ich muss sagen,
ich habe
– das ist tatsächlich die vegane.
Man merkt einfach null Unterschied.
>> JOSH: Nein.
Spaß.
>> SALLY: Man merkt wirklich nichts.
>> JOSH: Nee, merkt man nicht.
>> SARAH: Das ist gar nicht die vegane.
>> SALLY: Doch. Ich habe ja die vegane
einmal mit Sternchen gemacht
und einmal auch so aufgespritzt.
>> JOSH: Aber...
>> SARAH: Mhm.
Die haben aber Benny und Volkan gegessen.
>> SALLY: Mhm.
Ich habe doch sechs Stück oder so gehabt.
Okay, dann haben die die falsche gegessen.
>> SARAH: Sag es nicht.
>> SALLY: Nee, haben sie nicht.
>> SARAH: Das ist keine vegane.
>> SALLY: Okay, dann war das eine
– nee, ich habe gestern die Sterne-vegane gegessen,
gestern Abend.
>> SARAH: Da ist noch mal eine Sterne-vegane.
>> SALLY: Da war sie auch richtig gut.
Also Hammer!
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> SARAH: Mmh!
Çok güzel!
>> JOSH: Sehr, sehr, sehr lecker!
>> SARAH & SALLY: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also backt sie unbedingt nach
direkt
>> SARAH: Güzel heißt schön.
>> SALLY: in drei-, vierfacher Menge.
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Denn ihr müsst – also es ist so:
Bei der Linzertorte, da backt man nicht nur eine.
Weil die erste schneidet man direkt warm an,
>> JOSH & SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: die zweite ist man dann am nächsten Tag
und eigentlich ist die dritte, vierte
am übernächsten Tag die allerbeste.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und die hält sich ja auch locker...
>> SARAH: Oh, das ist voll der gute Lifehack!
>> SALLY: Ja. Eigentlich hält die sich locker zwei Wochen,
aber so lange hält die nie durch.
>> JOSH: Krasser Lifehack: Back drei Linzertorten.
>> SARAH: Vier!
Vier!
>> JOSH: Vier!
>> SARAH: Und iss die erste warm
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: und die anderen drei nach vier Tagen.
>> SARAH: Oder nach drei Tagen.
>> SALLY: Oh, lecker!
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich finde, wir müssen morgen noch mal probieren.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ich weiß nicht warum, aber das letzte Stück
will ich immer so nehmen und so abbeißen.
>> SARAH & JOSH: Hm.
[Musik]